make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering a cosmic Ghost Rider Meets
The Punisher now here's the important
thing to understand here this is kind of
an epilogue of sorts to the main revenge
of the cosmic Ghost Rider's story so it
doesn't really tie in directly to
everything going on in there it's just
more of something that happens at the
very end of the story but it's kind of
cool right because what this does is
this encounter between Frank Castle and
and cosmic Ghost Rider comes off the
heels of cosmic Ghost Rider ruins Marvel
history I think is what it's called
which from what I gather is a really
cool story I haven't really had a chance
to check it out yet let me know down in
the comments if you guys think it's a
really good story if you guys want to
see us cover it but what this does is it
initially picks up at the gravestone of
maria castle as well as the rest of the
castle family and initially it's kind of
cosmic Ghost Rider basically saying like
I'm done ripping through time and and
you know jumping through all those
escapades and and so on and so forth now
again cosmic Ghost Rider is Frank castle
from the future so it does kind of make
sense this is kind of where they're
they're know where this would lead to
but in the middle of it all he's met by
the arrival of Frank Castle in the
modern day I know that's one of the
important distinctions here is cosmic
Ghost Rider is Frank Castle at some
point along the line when Thanos killed
everybody on earth and the result was
that Frank Castle was basically given
the power of the Ghost Rider by Mephisto
in order to get revenge on Thanos the
issue was that he couldn't leave Earth
right so it's always kind of a catch-22
when it comes to my fist oh but with
Thanos essentially conquering the
universe for the most part killing most
of the entities aside from Galactus that
it eventually led to cosmic Ghost Rider
and Galactus teaming up and then
ultimately cosmic Ghost Rider joining
Thanos right so he is essentially from
the future but just kind of ended up
back in the modern day but Frank Castle
knows who he is but he knows who cosmic
Ghost Rider is and it's kind of crazy
because he basically says like you've
been running around with the Avengers
you know and spouting off about being
some kind of future version of me like
he didn't think I would hear about that
and that's how that's not a Punisher
knows who cosmic Ghost Rider is but it
is kind of funny because cosmic ghost
riders response is like huh I kind of
felt like you'd freak out when you heard
this when you found out that I was you I
kind of felt like you would lose your
mind right I like like you were just you
kind of go nuts and and to a degree
that's true we were sort of expect that
but one of the things that the Frank
Castle says is like I was friend ensign
at one point in time right I'm a lot
more open-minded then I get credit for
it and that's true there was one point
where Frank Castle I believe was cut to
pieces by dake in the Sun of Wolverine
and then was pieced back together again
as like Franken Castle it was a terrible
story but it was fun
it was kind of interesting but the long
and short is that a fight actually kind
of breaks out between the two of these
guys now this this is interesting right
because initially you would expect that
that Frank Castle wouldn't really have
much of an onslaught against cosmic
Ghost Rider now there is a precedent for
this technically Frank castle has faced
off against some pretty heavy hitters
but facing off against the Ghost Rider
came in 2014 I think it was and I
believe he went toe-to-toe with Robby
Reyes when I think it was Robby tried to
use the pennant stare on him and it
didn't work I don't number flew with
Robby Reyes or Johnny Blaze I don't know
which one off the top of my head but
during Dark Reign he went toe-to-toe
against the century right and was able
to hold his own now ultimately the fight
boiled down to him basically saying I
put a bomb and like some library or
something like that you got five seconds
before it goes off and then like he had
to basically race out of there so he
didn't really defeat him so much is like
forces hand into leaving kind of save
his own skin that way but Frank Castle
has routinely gone toe-to-toe against
some very powerful beings by doing
things like this he uses what are called
consecrated hellfire rounds you know any
literally says you're not my first
ghostwriter but it's kind of crazy
because he basically came loaded for
bear and he came prepared for this
conflict the issue is there's a
difference between Ghost Rider
and cosmic Ghost Rider right there's
just Ghost Rider who is an exceedingly
powerful character in and of himself
he's imbued by the power of a demon but
then you have cosmic Ghost Rider who's
who's enhanced even further with like
the power cosmic right hence the name
cosmic Ghost Rider and it's kind of nuts
because he basically blasts Frank Castle
with all this cosmic energy and then
says like you only survived because I
wanted you to write like I'm a former
Herald of the largest you're way out of
your league and then like when he goes
down to reach his hand like Frank Castle
stabs him in the head and the fight
breaks out yet again right now this is
one of the other cool things he says
he's using adamantium and vibranium and
using both of these things combined but
he essentially managed to stab cosmic
ghosts right and here's the funny thing
about this is I'm not really aware of
anything out there that's a combination
of adamantium and by bringing the
closest we get to that is the shield of
Captain America it's kind of interesting
the bigger question is how to get his
hands on right because like adamantium
was exceedingly hard to get your hands
on it's not impossible I want to know
how he got like I want to know how Frank
Haskell got out of an tiem I'm not aware
of him of us having a story where he did
and if he did then I want to read that
story because I imagine that story's
amazing but at the end of the day this
fight that Frank castles in he's just in
over his head but Lee there's no real
way for him to win this conflict with
the cosmic Ghost Rider nor do we expect
him to
nor would it would Marvel expect us to
bite there's a bigger thing going on
here and the bigger story that's really
kind of going on is he basically tells
cosmic Ghost Rider this is all your
fault
and when he asked him he's like what are
you even talking about right when he
overpowers Frank Castle and he's like
what are you talking about like Frank
Castle doesn't give up he's like get up
man like we've got a battle to fight
like goes to attack him again right
Frank hassle is usually never emotional
but Frank Castle is usually never
emotionally caught up that's one of the
things that's kind of a hallmark of his
character is he's dispassionate he's cut
off if you ever go when you read stories
like Punisher Punisher born by Garth
Ennis you do see him kind of get like
emotional at the end of the story when
he's fighting like hundreds of Vietcong
and like spraying them all down but if
you go and you read like Punisher max by
Garth Ennis which we're covering on
patreon you don't really see you know
any of these instances where he's like
overly emotional right it's just kind of
like clear and steady and he's gonna
kill you you know that kind of a thing
and so seeing I'm kind of freaking out
and seeing him lashing out means there's
something exceedingly personal about
this fight with himself and when the
question is what's your problem like
what in the heck is going on the
response of Frank Castle is you went
back in time you went back in time into
our universe and you could have changed
anything you could have changed anything
you wanted to why didn't you save them
why didn't you save our kids our wife
like why didn't you save our family why
didn't you do that and like cosmic Ghost
Rider kind of looked at him for a second
and then leash right if Frank hassle
starts freaking out you know he's like
he's like don't walk away from me you
got to answer me why didn't you save our
family and the response of the cosmic
Ghost Rider is because we deserved to be
punished too now what this means we
don't know but we can speculate now for
the most part Frank hassel didn't really
become the Punisher until the death of
his family right that was the catalyst
that led to him becoming the character
that we know so it's not as though he
didn't be exceedingly heinous things up
until that point but what we do know is
that if we take the run of Garth Ennis
as being in continuity which initially
it wasn't and then it was and I guess
maybe it kind of is we're not really
sure but if we take that as being in
continuity then we can basically look at
Punisher born what does it cover the
story that we covered and you'll find
that story down in the description but
in that story Frank Castle that's when
he really first led in his evil side
that's when you first loaded in the
darker side now the indication is that
it was Mephisto or some being like that
it was basically some kind of demonic
entity speaking to castle we can largely
kind of go with the fact that it was
Mephisto especially when you take the
entire
of cosmic ghostrider and you kind of
wrap it back into all of that it sort of
creates one great big huge cohesive
story where Mephisto has been waiting on
Frank Castle for decades right just kind
of waiting for him to get to that point
even for eons until they got to the
point where he could turn him into
cosmic or turn him into into the Ghost
Rider right so for the most part it was
kind of one of these things where it was
like in order to essentially survive the
night and Punisher born in the Vietnam
War The Punisher sort of sort of the
devil and it would kind of let out this
inner darkness now there's other
theories that say that it was just the
darker psychopathic side of Frank Castle
he was talking to himself there's no
real definitive answer given in that
story Garth Ennis doesn't really come
out and and you know say like have like
some splash page at the end of the end
of the story worse like and he was
talking to Mephisto the whole time
mostly because punishment max doesn't
really involve anything from the main
Marvel Universe outside of like Nick
Fury that's basically it but you know
it's usually one of these things where
like cosmic Ghost Rider could very well
be referencing the event to the Punisher
and saying like we deserve to be
punished too it could be one of these
things where he's basically looking at
who Frank Castle becomes because of the
death of his family and that he's not
doing a righteous thing he's not a
better person he becomes worse and so
it's one of these things were because of
who he becomes due to the death of his
family he deserves to be punished by
losing his family we don't really know
like we don't really know how that
circle gets squared we don't know if
cosmic Ghost Rider is referring to
himself and basically saying like
because of what I do you know alongside
Thanos we deserve to be punished but
largely we kind of have to look at that
and say all the things that Frank
castles done over the course of his life
following the death of his family is by
no means something he should be punished
for by losing his family who would Frank
hassel become had his family not died
yeah and that's that's really sort of
what this turns into that's why I say
the only real thing we could point to
you would be Punisher born like where he
basically sold his soul to the devil and
he deserved to be punished for it you
know by killing all those people and
becoming so exceedingly violent or being
somebody who made mistakes possibly was
on the take did some things that he
shouldn't have done in his past and
deserved be punished for it but again
you know it's very very ambiguous right
is is very very open-ended but it is a
very personal story here and that's what
makes it so cool is you get to see Frank
Castle in a way that you never really
see him right to see him in such a
personal moment to see him as a guy
who's like you could have saved our
family man like you could have saved my
why via our wife League you could have
saved our kids like we could have been
happy but instead like you chose not to
why didn't you give us a better life
it's interesting because it really kind
of points to the idea that if Frank
castle as he exists right now as the
Punisher
had the opportunity to go back in time
and save his family he would do it no
questions asked
it wouldn't be any if ands or buts he
would he would set the earth on fire
right he would move heaven and earth in
order to make that happen it's so cool
and so such a personal touch and I love
the way that it's done for that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
Robin Corps if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later Bruce
[Music]